[Music]
there's no doubt that Payton list is one
of the hottest stars right now with a
new TV show debuting in October 2018 and
three movies in the work she is on
everyone's radar but how much do we
really know about her stay tuned to find
out 20 fun facts about Peyton lists
can't get enough of all your favorite
stars and their movies why don't you
subscribe for more awesome content now
let's get to the 20 things you didn't
know about Peyton lists skorts
27 dresses baton lists first major role
was not on Disney Channel Dayton started
getting really small roles in 2002 when
she was only four years old but these
roles were all uncredited the first time
she had a pretty big role was in the
movie 27 dresses starring Katherine
Hegel this chick flick was all about a
woman who had been a bridesmaid in 27
weddings but could never find love of
her own Payton played the younger
version of the main character she was
only 10 years old at the time this role
really launched her into a successful
career and we are so glad it did twins
acting runs in the family
literally peyton has a twin brother
named Spencer they were born 10 minutes
apart on April 6 1998 Spencer is also an
actor but you probably won't recognize
him as easily his mostly had one-off
guest star roles on a bunch of different
TV shows but he's gonna be in the
upcoming movie anthem of a teenage
prophet with his twin sister how cool is
that Peyton and Spencer also have a
younger brother who's done some acting
too we guess you could call it a family
business she's an animal lover
the list family has two pet dogs named
Windsor and Gatsby
both of these pooches are rescues does
not just make you love her even more we
think it's amazing that they give a good
home to dogs who need it Peyton also has
a pet rabbit the rabbit's name is Claude
all her pets have super-classy names but
you won't believe how she got her pet
rabbit she saved it from a producer who
was gonna eat it Claude boy what why
would he eat a rabbit but Claude got a
happy ending Payton is basically a
Disney Princess with all her animal
rescues chick-flicks
Payton list loves a good chick flick
girls same she says her favorite movies
are romantic comedies from the 1990s and
early 2000s who can blame her old chick
flicks are the best we wonder if she
likes them so much because she's acted
in a few in addition to 27 dresses she
also had a small role in confessions of
a shopaholic and Something Borrowed
Peyton told Teen Vogue that she's
watched her favorite rom-coms hundreds
of times
we're totally tracking we love REE
watching our favorite movies model
student it can be totally weird to think
about celebrities going to school but
they have to get an education just like
the rest of us not only is Payton a
super talented actress she's also an
amazing student did you know she has a
4.0 GPA that means she has all A's
around here we call that goals she is
obviously really smart she was also
class president at one point and she
totally figured out how to win the
election she gave her classmates candy
that is so brilliant we bet she was an
awesome class president Payton is
seriously who we want to be at school
bus driver when you were a little kid
what did you want to be when you grew up
did you want to be a ballerina or a
doctor
well Payton didn't want to be either and
she didn't always want to be an actress
when she was little she had a very
unique career goal she wanted to be a
bus driver specifically she wanted to
drive a school bus she used to get in
trouble at school for talking she
thought that being a bus driver would
let her hang out with kids and talk all
day okay yeah that kind of makes sense
but we are super glad she became an
actress I'm super fashion woman faster
than an airport mani-pedi more powerful
than a platinum Charge Card seriously
what would we do without Payton on our
TVs the other Payton list Dayton is a
pretty original girl but she is not the
only Payton list there is another
actress with the same name the other
Payton list is 12 years older than our
Payton she's mostly a TV star she
starred on shows like Mad Men and
frequency one time the two actresses
stayed at the same hotel at the same
time the older Payton was accidentally
given the younger ones script talk about
confusing the two actresses have more
than just their name in common - they
have both made guest appearances on Law
& Order SVU
thinking besties is an order Oh
Payton currently lives in Los Angeles
where she spent the last several years
it totally makes sense to live in LA to
when all three kids in the family are
actors but Payton really considers
Brooklyn New York her home she grew up
there and so it's where her heart is
Payton has also said she would love to
live in Paris she loves French food and
French fashion and she loves big cities
seriously you guys Peyton would totally
look fierce in a beret on the streets of
Paris maybe one day she'll get a chance
to live there as long as she keeps
giving us awesome movies and TV shows
style icons Peyton is definitely one of
our style icons
she is a total fashionista and we love
seeing all her awesome clothes but who
is Peyton style icon she has said that
Blake Lively from Gossip Girl is totally
who she looks up to for her fashion
sense and who can blame her
Blake is always so stylish Peyton says
that her style is a mix of Blake Lively
and Olivia Palermo with a twist of her
room and that twist of her own is one of
the things we love most about Peyton she
is fashion goals did you know that she
turned her whole basement into a closet
we can only dream of having such an
amazing wardrobe the great outdoors
Peyton lives an active lifestyle and she
loves being outdoors her favorite hobby
is going hiking one of the things she
likes best about living in Los Angeles
is all the opportunities for hiking she
also enjoys swimming and other water
sports she learned to swim when she was
just a baby when she was a kid she
played basketball her nickname was the
octopus because she was a really
aggressive defensive player she's also
said that her perfect day would include
some sort of exercise it's pretty
awesome that she has so many cool
healthy hobbies musical talent not only
is Payton a talented actress she is also
a musician like a lot of Disney Channel
stars she's a great singer in fact back
in 2015 she was working on her debut
album that project was never finished
but maybe one day she'll get back to it
her acting career got really busy right
around that time I wish I had your life
my life would be so much better she also
sang on stage with a famous Mew
at the Greek Theatre she sang a duet
with Ingrid Michaelson Payton loves
music and she can memorize the lyrics to
any rap song after only hearing it twice
and when she's not singing other
people's lyrics she enjoys writing down
a few of her own as a hobby
daredevil Payton list is a bit of a
daredevil she loves being active and
taking risks and she loves amusement
parks when she first moved to Los
Angeles she went to an amusement park
every weekend total overkill she's
addicted to roller coasters she will
ride any ride and thinks the scarier the
ride is the better
she's also gone ziplining and she wants
to go skydiving her mom's would have
stopped at that when she was a teenager
but Payton is 20 now so we're sure
she'll jump out of a plane at some point
are you as much of a daredevil as Payton
phone addict Payton is totally addicted
to her phone and really who isn't a few
years ago she said her phone bills were
really high she loves social media like
Instagram and Twitter so she goes
through data like crazy she also has
games like a pimple popping app on her
phone gross she shares her phone
addiction with her character from Jessi
on one episode emma has to get a job to
pay for her phone bill because it's so
high good thing Dayton has a career to
pay for that phone bill in real life but
we totally understand being attached to
your phone Disney Princess as a Disney
Channel star Payton has been surrounded
by all things Disney for many years and
like all great Disney actresses it's fun
to know who her favorite Disney
Princesses penis said that Millan is her
favorite Disney character she thinks she
is super cool and looks amazing she
loves that Mulan is a fierce warrior
theme grew up with two brothers and can
hold her own in a fight so we can see
how she totally relates to Milan and why
she loves strong independent characters
like Milan face it she is a pretty
original independent person herself
biggest fear even though she can be a
daredevil Peyton isn't totally fearless
like
she has some irrational fears her
biggest fear is getting stuck on the
subway one time her uncle was stuck on
the subway between stations for four
hours he had to squeeze out of the doors
and walk along the tracks in the dark
scary tunnel can you say terrifying ever
since she heard that story Payton is
scared of it happening to her well she
isn't scared of the dark being stuck in
an underground tunnel is a whole
different thing okay now we're totally
freaked out about that - foody we know
Payton keeps an active lifestyle but
what does she eat to fuel her busy life
she loves chocolate croissants she says
acai bowls are her jam she once told
Disney Channel that her perfect day
would include going to brunch with her
family um brunch + family yeah perfect
day we can see it she says she'll eat
breakfast foods all day every day it is
the most important meal of the day after
all it seems that Payton can also cook
she said she makes a mean macaroni and
cheese does that mean she makes it from
the blue box or from scratch um doesn't
matter
also we're kind of hungry now role
models Payton has worked with some
amazing actresses in her career people
have school are calling me Zuri sister
she has a lot of people to look up to
but she has two people she names as her
acting role models and the two women are
both former Disney Channel stars one of
her role models is debby ryan the
actress who played Peyton's nanny on
Jessie Debbie Ryan is now on the hit
show insatiable Payton also really
admires Emma Stone did you know Emma
once appeared on The Suite Life of Jack
and Cody
Peyton thinks emma is a great actress
and has done some amazing work both of
these actresses are amazing and we can
totally see why Peyton looks up to them
terrible vision we love seeing Peyton on
TV in movies and all over social media
but we would have never guessed that she
has terrible vision she wears contacts
Peyton has said that she is blind as a
bat she cannot see without glasses or
contacts so how did she find out she
needed to visit the
my daughter when she was in fourth grade
she was playing basketball her mom
noticed she kept passing the ball to
players on the opposite team so she took
Payton in for an eye exam um that is
kind of an adorable and hilarious story
at the same time and we're glad she
figured it out
lipstick obsession Payton's makeup game
is always on point she always looks so
put together and get this she does her
own makeup that girl has some serious
skills
she's also absolutely addicted to
lipstick she has to have it with her
everywhere she goes and she doesn't just
carry one or two colors at a time she
carries a ton at one point she counted
the lipsticks and glosses she had in her
bag she had 20 that is obsession on a
whole other level but a girl needs
variety right for a while her favorite
shades were maroon but she also loves to
mix it up upcoming work after leaving
Disney Channel earlier in 2018 Payton
has become a super busy actress her
movie anthem of a teenage prophet comes
out in October 2018 as well as the hulu
original TV show light as a feather
which she has already filmed ten
episodes she also has two other films
that are post-production then came u
debuts in April of 2019 and a remake of
valley girl but that project has been
shelved for a while we have a feeling
we're gonna be seeing a lot more of
Peyton lists so which of Peyton's
projects are you most excited about let
us know in the comments and those are
twenty fun facts about Peyton lists hey
don't forget to subscribe for more
awesome videos see you next time
[Music]